[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous nous sommes
dans parlement hebdo la loi bioéthique
et la lutte contre la haine sur internet
sont deux grands temps forts cette
semaine à l'ordre du jour
bonjour table bonjour carrière et un
sénateur est avec nous pour commenter
cette semaine parlementaire bernard
jomier bonjourbonjour sénateur apparenté
socialiste de paris
on va commencer tout de suite par votre
portrait redoutable et oui bernard
jomier vous êtes né à clermont-ferrand
mais vous avez préféré les buttes
chaumont à la chaîne des puys pour votre
carrière politique
vous êtes élu de paris du 19ème
arrondissement depuis près de 20 ans élu
sénateur il ya seulement deux ans et
demi en 2017 vous êtes écologistes mais
siéger au groupe socialiste au sénat
votre signe distinctif vous êtes médecin
vous allez me dire vous n'êtes pas le
seul au parlement mais chez vous ça a eu
un impact sur votre carrière politique
de quelle façon à battre est très
clairement parce que quand on est
médecin moi je suis médecin généraliste
dans un quartier du 19e qui est un
quartier très populaire est en fête avec
d'autres on ya créé une association de
quartier parce que il y avait un
urbanisme à paris qui sévissent est à
l'heure actuelle menée par alors à
l'époque menée par jean tiberi qui était
maire de paris qui était de densifier à
outrance c'est de là qu'est née votre
engagement et donc l'engagement dans
l'écologie a pris ses racines là
l'engagement donc dans la politique
aussi j'étais dans le monde associatif
mais pas dans la politique
moi j'ai adhéré pour la première fois un
parti politique très tard j'avais 38 ans
et donc je me suis présenté deux ans
après aux élections municipales
donc c'est bien la vie locale des
problématiques locales et mon métier de
médecin parce que j'étais médecin j'ai
et je suis toujours médecins
généralistes dans ce même quartier
donc il y à une confluence entre toutes
ces approches qui ont fait ce que
j'essaye de faire dans la vie publique
trois thèmes parlementaires à l'ordre du
jour bernard journée pour vous c'est
fait la pma pour toutes les fans étendue
le sénat a voté son extension mais pas
le remboursement pour toutes
les députés ont adopté une proposition
de loi pour lutter contre les contenus
haineux sur internet les contenus
illicites devront être retirés sous 24
heures et puis la suite des auditions
devant la commission d' enquête du sénat
sur l' incendie de lubrizol de la
poussière d'amiante se serait propagée
dans l'air selon certains témoignages et
on passe au premier thème de cette
émission la pma pour toutes
[Musique]
le sénat après l'assemblée nationale
examine le projet de loi de bioéthique
vous en êtes d'ailleurs l'un des
rapporteurs un bernard jomier cette
semaine les sénateurs ont adopté l'une
des mesures phares l'ouverture de la pma
aux couples de femmes et aux femmes
célibataires résumé des débats par
sandra cerqueira la pression de la manif
pour tous devant le sénat deux soirs de
suite
sono à fond et drapeaux agités n'y a
rien fait pour l'adoption 160 contre 116
bon dans la nuit de mercredi les
sénateurs ont adopté l'article 1 qui
ouvre la pma toutes les femmes grâce à
une majorité hétéroclite rassemblant
droite gauche centre est en marche
un vote sur lequel peu de monde aurait
parié il ya quelques mois la droite est
restée divisée mais au sein du groupe lr
nombreux sont ceux qui ont évolué sur le
sujet je ne vote pas la loi ni sur ces
sujets là ni sur les autres en fonction
de mes convictions personnelles mais en
fonction de mon intime conviction de ce
qui peut se faire de mieux
ou deux du moins mal possible pour la
société et pour les évolutions bruno
retailleau président du groupe l'est
républicain s'est retrouvé mis en
minorité par le vote du sénat il a
combattu jusqu'au bout la pma dénonçant
les conséquences d'un enfant sans père
de faire naître les enfants dans ces
conditions là pouvaient nous interroger
je pense qu'on doit dans cet hémicycle
être capable d'échanger des arguments le
sujet des familles monoparentales a
particulièrement fait débat celui du
remboursement de la pma pour tout aussi
la droite s'y est opposée pour les
couples de lesbiennes et femmes seuls
modifiant ainsi le projet de loi initial
quelle serait la légitimité d'un
financement par l'assurance maladie de
quelque chose qui ne relèvent en aucun
cas d'une indication médicale parce que
l'assurance maladie n'est pas fait pour
ça c'est une charge est dû on est là en
fait sur un problème qui à mon avis bien
plus antérieure qui est une grande
réticence avec amp ha d'honneur qui est
une concession pour les couples
hétérosexuels mais concessions que vous
ne faites pas à l'égard des couples
lesbiens
parce qu'en fait vous
or dénier le droit d'avoir des enfants
et de les élever le sénat dit donc oui à
la pma mais en limitant son
remboursement aux seuls critères médical
d'infertilité
les débats sur la loi de bioéthique se
poursuivre jusqu'au 30 janvier avant un
vote solennel prévu le 4 février
prochain
bernard jomier on l'a vu au début de ce
reportage il ya encore eu des
manifestants devant le sénat mais tout
de même on est quand même loin du
mariage pour tous les débats on était
beaucoup plus apaisé un mois d'abord sur
le contexte alors les débats ont été
tout à fait respectueux avec des
échanges d'arguments qui ont été on va
dire profond et sérieux et moi je salue
l'ensemble des positions qui ont été
exprimés parce que c'est ça le l'intérêt
du parlement et son importance c'est que
les différentes opinions s'y exprime
bien dans le parlement
et après au terme du débat on vote on
prend une décision est la décision la
première chose à noter c'est qu'elle est
très nette
la majorité qui a adopté est très nette
au sénat
et c'est un peu ces majorités politiques
type 1975 doit veille
si c'est le même type de majorité c'est
à dire olivier geay très majoritairement
à 95%
la gauche est très minoritairement la
droite et tout ça a fait une majorité
oui et donc ça veut dire que
politiquement ce n'est pas du tout
payant pour la droite d'être contre la
pma pour tout c'est ça que ça veut dire
aussi puisqu'il ce consensus
on le prévoyait pas forcément il ya
quelques mois quand on essayé d'imaginer
ce que serait le débat au sénat la
droite sénatoriale la droite sénatoriale
essais et je fais cette précision parce
que je pense que le sénat al'avantage
d'être plus en réflexion est en retrait
je le dis sans aucune critique vis-à-vis
de nos collègues députés bien sûr mais
les députés sont dans l'instantané dans
la le combat politique dans
l'affrontement
au sénat nous sommes dans la réflexion
d'un prix national on a vu aussi que
françois-xavier bellamy ça n'avait pas
payé on a qu'on pense aussi que la
droite plus globalement à tyrien aussi
les leçons il assure être trop
conservateur au niveau sociétal c'est
pas payant il ya certainement une
analyse politique car de considérations
moins nobles mais tout de même je moi je
donne acte du fait que il ya eu ce recul
qui a été pris au fond moi j'ai entendu
des collègues
sénateurs comme la roger karoutchi dire
en gros
moi je suis pas d'accord avec la pma
pour les femmes et pour les couples de
femmes
mais comme la société le veut je ne suis
pas gardien de l'évolution des moeurs et
ça je crois que c'est très important
des parlementaires n'ont pas édicter
l'évolution des moeurs
ils ont apposé les règles qui font que
cette évolution ne porte atteinte à
personne donc ça veut dire que la
société évolue et le sénat s'adapte à
ces changements de société le sénat lui
aussi capable d'évoluer
ça vous étonne c'est une question et le
sénat vous savez est une chambre qui est
globalement conservées très je ne suis
pas dans la majorité sénatoriale
mais rappelez vous que quand robert
badinter ne menu devant le sénat à
défendre l'abolition de la peine de mort
le sénat a voté l'abolition de la peine
de mort
et donc on a parfois une image un peu
caricatural oui le sénat est à majorité
conservatrice
non ce n'est pas une chambre qui est
figé alors le sénat tout de même à
refuser le remboursement par la sécurité
sociale de la pma pour les couples de
femmes
le remboursement se fera seulement sur
des critères d'infertilité dans la
version du sénat ce que pour vous ça
c'est légitime non c'est très
regrettable alors ça procès de deux
types d'arguments il ya ceux qui sont
opposés à la pma et qui mène un combat
d'arrière garde qui essayait sont
cohérents avec eux mêmes cela oui enfin
en même temps quand un droit est adoptée
conte et parlementaires ont fait en
sorte que ce ne soit pas un droit formel
mais que ce soit un droit réel et fictif
qui s'applique et donc vouloir poser des
verrous
tout le long de la procédure qui a
abouti à l'adoption la pma ce n'est pas
à mon avis très digne de la fonction de
parlementaire
il ya un deuxième type d'argument qui a
été porté par le présent la commission
des lois libye dit que ce n'est pas dans
les gènes de la sécurité sociale de
prendre en charge ce type de défense et
ça c'est une vision très étriqué du rôle
de la sécurité sociale je rappellerai
juste que quand la sécurité sociale a
été créé l'essentiel des dépenses
c'était les indemnités journalières
puis ce furent les soins est de plus en
plus ce sont des dépenses de prévention
dont la part augmente et donc il n'y a
absolument rien de choquant quand on se
met en dynamique à dire que la sécurité
social va prendre en charge une
procédure dont personne ne conteste que
la procédure et médicales oui massif
dans la maternité n'est pas une maladie
elle est remboursée par la sécurité
sociale c'est le contre argument qu'on a
réussi plus longtemps donc incertain de
l'argan mais cette évolution des
présences de la sécurité sociale nous
devons l'accompagner
donc ce sont des arguments qui sont pas
très recevable donc pour vous il faut
que ce soit remboursée pour toutes les
femmes sans discrimination sans
inégalités
sinon on crée deux catégories de femmes
et puis il faut être très clair
derrière cet argument médicale il y a en
fait de prendre en charge la pma pour
les couples hétérosexuels et de ne pas
le prendre en charge pour les couples de
femmes lesbiennes ou les femmes seules
donc il y as derrière une discrimination
évidente lorsque les craintes que cela
ouvre la porte à la gpa aux mères
porteuses notamment pour les couples
d'hommes
est ce que cette crainte là pour vous
est fondée je sais pas s'il faut parler
de crainte
il est clair que nous vivons un
changement de paradigme dans la
parentalité la parentalité
traditionnellement étaient biologiques
et uniquement biologique
quand l'adoption a été acceptée pour les
hommes seuls et pour les femmes seules
d'abord il ya des le lien biologique et
délié mais deuxième effet tout aussi
important le lien entre pour les femmes
entre la maternité et la sexualité est
aussi déliés alors on me dira que ce
sont des exceptions et que c'est
simplement la résolution une situation
qu un enfant est orphelin mais la
réalité c'est que ce changement de
modèle de parentalité qui fait que
différents types de famille existe n'est
pas accepté par tout le monde
est ce que ce changement de modèle ira
jusqu'à la gestation pour autrui
il faut juste prendre 30 secondes mais
gestation pour autrui c'est un fait
à l'heure actuelle il existe il faut pas
fermer les yeux elle existe allez on
déjà être mangés les qui lui avait remis
en france mais elles existent à
l'étranger
elles existent pour des couples
hétérosexuels pour les deux donc c'est
une réalité
c'est une réalité d'ailleurs on ne sait
légitime que ça ouvre le débat
ce n'est pas ce que je dis que le débat
soit posée oui bien sûr que la
résolution est une autre chose mais en
tout cas nous devons convenir que la gpa
existe est ce que ça la rend inéluctable
par 100 dans son inscription dans la loi
non mais pas inéluctables mais on a dit
que c'était pour des raisons d'égalité
qu'on ouvre la pma à toutes les femmes
en france à ce que les couples d'hommes
qui ne peuvent avoir d'enfants que par
la gestation pour autrui ce qui serait
pas légitime qui disent pour des raisons
d'égalité on demande la légalisation
nous aussi en france si vous si vous
posez le seul argument de l'égalité oui
mais il n'ya pas que le seul argument
d'égalité nous avons des valeurs
éthiques fondamentales dans notre pays
est une de ces valeurs et la non
marchandisation du corps humain et donc
il faut respecter chacune de ces valeurs
quand le législateur prend une décision
donc c'est une situation complexe dont
on a débattu longuement hier soir au
sénat à propos d'un amendement qui nous
a fait un peu entré par le petit bout de
la lorgnette débat retailleau bono la
fille qui s'en prend aux enfants
ce que je trouve pas très courageux ils
sont déjà nés à l'étranger il faut que
ceux qui voudraient mettre fin à cet
état de fait bah propose de s'en prendre
aux couples mais il est visiblement ils
n'ont pas le courage donc ils s'en
prennent aux enfants en tout cas moi je
ne soutiens pas du tout ce type de
solution il faut respecter l'intérêt de
l'enfant alors en tout cas on continuera
à suivre ce débat sur ce projet loi
puisque c'est une procédure législative
normal ça veut dire que le texte
absolument revenir à ben ce n'est pas le
cas de la plupart des textes lutter
contre la diffusion de contenus haineux
sur internet c'est l'objectif d'une
proposition de loi qui a été adoptée
cette semaine à l'assemblée
[Musique]
le texte est porté par la députée de la
majorité laetitia avia il prévoit que
les plateformes et moteurs de recherche
devront retirer les contenus
manifestement illicite en 24 heures sous
peine de sanction cette année des
pierres 24 heures pas une de plus c'est
le délai donné aux plateformes
numériques pour retirer les contenus
manifestement illicite
c'est à dire les incitations à la haine
à la violence
les injures racistes ou religieuse ou
encore le harcèlement sexuel pour les
contenus terroristes ou
pédopornographiques
le délai est encore plus court en cas de
signalement par les autorités il faudra
aller retirer en une heure ce texte
porté par la députée de la majorité
laetitia via est très controversée la
restriction des libertés individuelles
en ligne risque d'une trop grande
censure de la part des plateformes peur
que facebook google ou twitter ne
s'érigent en juges de la liberté
d'expression les craintes sont
nombreuses du côté des associations
comme des députés les républicains la
gauche de la gauche le rassemblement
national et quelques centristes ont donc
voté contre cette proposition de loi
pour lutter contre la cyber n elle doit
encore repasser au sénat avant son
adoption définitive
le 11 février à l'assemblée la marge au
risque pour vous cette proposition de
loi est vraiment utile et ce qu'elle
permet de lutter efficacement contre eux
la cyberhaine le cyber harcèlement
c'est une proposition de loi qui fait
relativement accord on va dire dans ces
constats on voit bien que les réseaux
sociaux sont un lieu un peu un contrôle
et où on se fait injurier très
facilement
la loi de bioéthique il ya quelques
instants
imaginez ce que les rapporteurs de cette
loi reçoivent comme messages sur les
réseaux sociaux et ces essais étaient
directement liées à l'importance des
thèmes qui sont traités alors le constat
fait fait accord ce que c'est utile de
les gérer
après légiférer
on ne règle pas ces sur la question de
la montée de la violence y compris ce
donc sur les réseaux sociaux en
l'occurrence dans notre pays par une loi
il y a de façon générale un contexte un
peu de perte de civilité on va dire où
les réseaux sociaux étant le lieu de
l'absence de contre réaction quand vous
avez quelqu'un en face de vous vous êtes
modéré quand vous avez un écran et vous
exprimer en 140 ou 286 n'y a aucune
monnaie fait pour lutter contre ceux qui
les doigts déferlement de haine
la proposition des auteurs de cette loi
pose des solutions qui sont qui pose
quelques elle même quelques problèmes
oui bien par exemple le point qui
concentre les critiques effectivement
c'est le délai de 24 heures qui est
donné aux plateformes en ligne pour
retirer les contenus manifestement
illicite
c'est un point qui avait été retiré par
le sénat retable rétabli par l'assemblée
ça pour vous ça pose problème va le
délai en soit 24 heures c'est ce que
signifie ce délai de 24 heures
il signifie que l'opérateur de la plate
forme va avoir le pouvoir de lui même de
posséder au retrait or moi je pense que
vu les des sultans d'interprétation il
va y avoir conflit
vu la difficulté à respecter dans notre
pays la liberté d'expression il ya
beaucoup dans thor salé liberté
d'expression depuis quelques années il
faudrait qu'un le juge des référés
interviennent d'accord on ne peut pas je
n'essaie pas le délai mais c'est ce
n'est pas le redresser parce que le
pouvoir donné aux quatre formes dans un
délai aussi court est un pouvoir qui est
un peu extraordinaire du droit commun
actuel c'est dangereux pour la liberté
d'association et veille à un risque il
ya un risque effectivement et la balance
est toujours complexe à établir mais ces
dérapages qui sont inacceptables ne
peuvent pas être combattue nom prénom
plus au prix d'une mise en cause trop
forte de la liberté d'opinion et exprès
d'expression donc ce délai créé cette
difficulté de par l'absence de contrôle
du juge des référés est par ailleurs
cette loi en visant les réseaux sociaux
finit par visait la presse aussi on est
là la réponse de la ministre sur le
sujet est très claire on ne peut pas
différencier
la règle en fonction que c'est un
journaliste ou un particulier qui
s'exprime et donc il y à un risque
d'atteintes aux droits de la presse et
dans le contexte de l'actuelle ça ne me
semble pas être une dosette contredire
que c'est difficile de légiférer sur ce
point
est ce que ce n'est pas aussi difficile
parce que ce n'est entre guillemets
qu'une proposition de loi une
proposition de loi qui est allé vite en
procédure accélérée qui est quasiment la
norme depuis le début du quinquennat
depuis un certain nombre d'années on a
connu un chef de l'état qui dès qu'il y
avait un problème
envoyez loi à l'assemblée au parlement
et pensait régler le problème par cette
loi
c'était nicolas sarkozy bon la
précipitent à blaye ne date pas d'hier
la précipitation et bave pas bonne
conseillère en la matière le temps de la
loi plus la question est complexe plus
le temps de la loi il est important
qu'il soit suffisant on l'a vu sur la
loi de bioéthique vous l'avez rappelé
c'est pour la première fois depuis le
début de ce quinquennat qu'une loi est
en procédure normale
toutes les lois sont étudiées en
procédure accélérée
et quand les auteurs de cette loi est
ici à avia l'on déposé le gouvernement a
demandé tout de suite la procédure
accélérée pour lui faut du temps pour
faire une bonne loi c'est ça du faut du
temps pour apporter des réponses lisible
à des questions complexes avec une place
du juge importante laissée aux
dispositifs ça sera là la modification
que vous souhaiter pour la prochaine
lecture au sénat le juge des référés
interviennent alors on va passer bernard
jomier au dernier sujet de cette
émission les révélations de la
commission d' enquête sur lubrizol au
sénat
[Musique]
six mois après l'incendié de rouen les
sénateurs ont auditionné cette semaine
le professeur andré picot ce chimiste et
spécialiste de toxicologie a alerté sur
les risques liés à l'amiante notamment
pour certains pompiers intervenus sur
place regardez cet entrepôt énorme avait
un toit en fibrociment offs avec le
fibrociment est à base d'amiante qu'il y
avait des bouteilles sûrement de gaz
comprimés ce qui ont explosé qui ont
comme des fusées ont pulvérisé
complètement ce toit immense et l'on
dispersé on a retrouvé à deux kilomètres
des morceaux d'amiante
mais surtout ce qui était très embêtant
c'est que hill et retombe les gens de
pluie de poussière d'amiante une des
propriétés de l'amiante est assez
spécifique de l'amiante c'est de
déclencher des cancers de l'envelope des
poumons
madame busin a demandé des analyses
qu'est ce qu'elle a demandé comme
analyse de ces pompiers
des analyses de sang de l'état du foie
des pompiers or fait tout le monde sait
très bien qu'une fille n'y en a aucun
impact sur le foie et qu'il aurait mieux
fait il aurait mieux fait de vérifier un
petit peu l'état de leurs tractus
pulmonaire bernard genin rappelle que
vous êtes donc médecins à ce que vous
partagez les inquiétudes de ceux
toxicologue qui parle donc et bien des
résultats que pourraient avoir ces
particules d'amiante tout c'est tout cet
amiante qui a été dégagée avec
l'incendié du grisolles je crois qu'on a
bien fait de mettre en place une
commission denquête au sénat sur cette
question et pourquoi est ce qu'on l'a
mise en place parce qu'on a vu dès les
jours qui ont suivi l'incendié de
lubrizol une première période de flou où
le gouvernement ne disait pas grand
chose au cafouillage les autorités ne
disait pas concevoir et je vais y venir
parce que c'est plus qu'un cafouillage
de communication à mon sens et puis au
bout d'une es8 dix jours plusieurs
ministres sont allés ensemble sur place
pour tenir un discours qui était un peu
lunaire qui était de dire ne vous en
faites pas on va prendre toutes les
mesures et tout ira bien
non ce que ce que dit lubrizol
c'est peut-être la goutte de trop qui
fait boire déborder le vase de la façon
dont on gère les questions de santé
environnementale dans notre pays notre
système d' alerte ne fonctionne pas il
fonctionne très mal notre système
d'évaluation et de prise en charge est
défaillant et ce n'est pas que moi qui
le dit ce ne serait pas grave mais nous
sortons du troisième plan de santé
environnementale le quatrième est en
cours d'évaluation et l'évaluation par
les gas du troisième plan est
extrêmement généreux chance l'inspection
générale vous expliquer cet état de fait
on a intégré les leçons de ce qui s'est
passé
nous avons un problème il ya eu d'autres
accidents industriels c'est ça c'est
pour ça que je dis que c'est la goutte
de trop et donc puisque nous avons des
problèmes de gouvernance en santé
environnementale dans notre pays dans la
façon dont elle est organisée
l'évaluation dont la transparence est
mise en oeuvre la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat m'a demandé
d'effectuer un travail sur cette
question donc sur les priorités la
gouvernance en santé environnementale
que je débuterai dans quelques jours et
nous rendrons un rapport sur le sujet
pour proposer des solutions parce que
lubrizol venant après d'autres scandales
de santé environnementale et bien
d'autres problèmes en la matière on voit
bien qu'on ne peut pas rester dans ce
type de gouverner un problème de
gouvernance vous dites c'est
exceptionnellement la réalisation savez
nous avons un système un peu mix nous
avons des agences nous enverrons
plusieurs on ne sait pas exactement qui
pilote le ces agences sont elle même
contestée et moi je je comprends vous
prenez l'ansès regarder le conseil
d'administration de lens s il y a deux
dents des intérêts privés des intérêts
industriels
l'ineris que la ministre de la santé a
missionné ch faire des études
il y a dans le conseil d'administration
de l'ineris le directeur de l'union des
industries chimiques bon je ne dis pas
que les différents partenaires doivent
pas être partie prenante mais ça ne
garantit ni l'indépendance ni la
transparence de la prise en charge de
ces questions et si on revient sur ce
cas précis sur la question de l'amiante
on a clairement deux versions à la
version du gouvernement qui dit qu'il a
diligenté des campagnes de mesure et que
les conclusions sont rassurantes et puis
vous
et c'est toxicologue indépendant qui a
un ancien chercheur du cnrs qui explique
mais ce n'est pas possible il ya eu
forcément de la poussière d'amiante qui
a été dégagé alors qui croire
moi je fais coucou alors là totalement
confiance à mes collègues de la
commission denquête pour demander et
obtenir les informations nécessaires à
l'établissement la vérité mais les
habitants de rouen et des environs ont
le droit de savoir ce qui s'est passé et
l'ensemble des français a le droit de
savoir comment on prend en charge ce
type de catastrophes industrielles dans
notre pays
comment on y répond et comment
l'impératif de santé publique est
considérée c'est à dire est ce une
priorité ou n'est ce pas une priorité
est ce que vous pensez qu'en tout cas la
commission denquête mise en place au
sénat va réussir à avoir des éléments a
obtenu à faire la lumière sur certaines
zones d'ombré c'est compliqué parce que
c'est un sujet très technique parfois
avec eux ils ont beaucoup dit il on est
on est pas chez mr reçoit des analystes
c'est compliqué aussi pour un
parlementaire de faire ce travail là sur
un sujet divise sur l'issue dans notre
pays on a par canal sentiment que ces
questions relèvent du secret défense
c'est pas le cas tellement mais bien
évidemment ça n'est pas du tout le cas
en l'occurrence n'est pas une commission
d'enquêté c'est pas les dingues ça dit
bien la difficulté qu'ont les
gouvernements à faire face à sète à ces
questions c'est à dire que
l'environnement les risques industriels
impact sur notre santé
on sait que c'est de plus en plus
important
les découvertes récentes par exemple sur
l'épigénétique on n'exprime pas un gène
en fonction de l'environnement vous
restez mobilisés récente nous disent
qu'il faut vraiment travailler plus
complètement sur ses claques juste un
tout dernier mot sur le fait que la
l'usinage repris sa production au mois
de décembre à ce que c'était pour vous
une bonne chose ou était-ce prématuré on
sait que c'était aussi un gros enjeu
économique pour la région
je pense que ce qui est dommage c'est de
ne pas avoir à ne pas être là elle est
plus vite dans l'établissement de la
vérité sur ce qui s'est passé là bas ce
sera le mot de la fin
ben je dis merci beaucoup d'avoir été
l'invité de cette émission merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette émission à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]